welcome back to the omex logic
bioinformatics for precision medicine
program in this video we will be
reviewing what we have learned in
session one the first session was
designed to give you a good sense of
bioinformatic applications in precision
medicine after completing the session
video and associated resources you will
have a good grasp on how data analysis
skills and next generation sequencing
technologies are used today in the field
by now you will have also learned about
the various examples that highlight the
role of precision medicine in diverse
range of fields from oncology
neuroscience to even infectious diseases
to briefly review what we have learned
in section one first we took a look at
various data sources that are used to
understand clinical decisions these
consist of basic patient details their
clinical history and finally the
molecular profiling data we discussed
about what is clinical data what is
molecular data and where do they come
from but what was interesting to learn
was the growing importance of molecular
data and how their association with
clinical data can help refine strategies
for diagnostics and therapy selection
their importance can be seen as we
discussed in the case of herceptin a
targeted therapeutic that has been used
to treat her2-positive breast cancer
patients that led to an increase in the
rate of breast cancer survival
other multi-atomic studies has also
helped change the way we understand
cancers for example we discussed about
how integrated analysis of multi-organs
data has led to a much better
understanding of liver cancer risk such
as infection with hepatitis b and c as
well as other factors like alcohol
consumption ethnicity and other
comorbidities
such comprehensive studies continue to
yield results even today that improve
the way treatment is delivered and even
find new treatments
next we explore the role of next
generation sequencing or what is also
known as high throughput sequencing in
transforming the field of medicine omix
technologies like mgs can be used to
explore the role relationships and
actions of the various types of
molecules many types of omics data can
be generated using ngs and these omics
data describe in great detail the
intracellular and intercellular
processes associated with common
diseases
these datasets can be analyzed to
understand the biology behind host
factors microbiome composition in our
bodies the type of environments that we
live in that drive infection and various
factors that lead to clinical
manifestation of diseases
finally we learned about the process of
how discovering the lab leads to
real-life applications here mainly we
explore three topics cell line
experiments animal models of human
diseases and how they offer rich
collection of data to inform diagnosis
and treatment of cancer in patients
we also discussed some of the main
projects carried out for example the
cancer genome atlas that aims to explore
the entire spectrum of genomic changes
involved in human cancer another project
discussed was the all of us research
program that is building one of the
largest biomedical data resources of its
kind finally we discussed about the
human microbiome project that aims to
characterize the
human microbiome in normal individuals
to determine if changes in the
microbiome can be correlated with
disease and health
after reviewing the rationale for
bioinformatics and ngs in biomedical
research and the clinic we reviewed some
case studies for example we discussed
the spread of best african ebola virus
sarcop2 genomes and cell responses as
well as how the microbiome is associated
with disease and drug response
we also reviewed some example projects
designed to illustrate how
bioinformatics is used in real world
examples from inherited mutations in
sickle cell anemia to mycobacterium
tuberculosis
finally to benefit from today's lecture
we discuss some of the associated
resources that you can go through to
refresh your memory learn more or
practice what we have learned in today's
session
a good place to start with is lesson 2
bioinformatics and healthcare from
course 1 introduction to bioinformatics
here you will also see examples and
videos of medical professionals
discussing bioinformatics in precision
medicine applications
after gaining an overview of examples
from healthcare where bioinformatics can
be applied you can start with course two
bytes and molecules this course is for
anyone who wants to review the basic
terminology and get a good overview of
topics we cover in this course
materials we cover today can be found in
lesson six in production two genomics of
bytes and molecules that will cover
fundamental concepts in ngs and various
genomic project examples
another great course is course 3
genomics this course serves as an
introduction to the bioinformatics
sub-discipline of genomics in this
course lesson 2 working with dna
sequences in r will get you started on
learning about dna and turn to sequence
alignment to find notations that can
help treat patients better all done by
coding an r
then you will also learn from lesson
three introduction to genomics that will
help you familiarize with the biology of
genetics and genetic variation
the full course contains a lot more
information that you can choose to
explore independently some of these will
be covered in the future lectures as
well so do not worry about completing
them for now
finally we took a brief glance at what
we will be covering in the upcoming
session that is session two genomic data
analysis here you will go one step
further to better understand what is
genomic data how do you perform gradient
calling analysis what is the difference
between germline and somatic mutation
what is its clinical relevance at the
end of session 2 you will have a
thorough understanding of genomics data
variant calling analysis as well as
specific techniques for clinical
annotation in cancer